hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen zu einer weiteren folge gold
simulator einige hatten bemängelt dass
kojima ein bisschen langweilig wir da
ich immer auf den gleichen map war und
deswegen habe ich jetzt wieso ist da
unten was ist denn das da unten
deswegen habe ich mir jetzt das
vorgestern erschienene pay day update
gekauft und da sind wir jetzt hier mit
einer neuen sieger wird am status ist
nämlich jimmy jimmy blue ochsenknecht
herrig dummkopf kessenich ochsenknecht
der heißt ja ziegen knecht wie blöd ich
bin ich habe gerade überlegt was ich als
nächsten card nehme und dann steht die
tante da einfach auf und jetzt kannst du
auf einmal wieder gehen was ist das für
eine alltag das ist eine richtig
komische tante die teleportiert sich
wirklich nicht mehr jedenfalls ist pay
day soll zusätzliche motti man sich
kaufen kann für 5 euro oder so da bin
ich jetzt halt dieses tolle geschöpf
hier und stehe hier so imposant rum und
das was habe ich jetzt schon wieder
getan
ich weiß nicht was es bedeutet wenn ich
jetzt diese maske hierauf habe aber
irgendwas scheint dann wohl zu passieren
und ich kann die die charaktere wechseln
nämlich so drücke da bin ich nämlich er
hier unten jetzt ein baby delphine und
wegen der vielen versuche jetzt erst mal
kurz hier irgendwie raus zu kommen
freunde was ich sagen kann ich auch noch
diesen flamingo hier nehmen mit dem ich
kann fliegen was geht
das ist nämlich die neue stadt hier das
ist die pay day statt und da kann ich
jetzt halt diese vier leute steuern ich
zeige vielleicht noch den vierten und
ich weiß nicht was peter ist das müsste
eben immer in die kommentare schreiben
aber das ist nicht eine riesiges das ist
doch nicht
wow ich bin komplett begeistert von
diesem spiel hier oben läuft ein typ rum
der anscheinend das leben tatsächlich
sehr doll genießt mal schauen weg in
slate nach zwölf sekunden habe ich jetzt
gesehen er tanzt einfach weiter auf dem
bürgersteig
das ist gott hätte meine damen und
herren wird diese biotope legs of
display ball her mein gott was ist das
für ein spiel ich hätte echt gerne den
kompletten polizei bittet mich mit ich
bin ein verrückter flamingo boxer bitte
ich ich brauche hilfe
ich brauche wirklich hilfe ich hätte
echt lust einfach gold simi later nur
noch hochzuladen das macht einfach so
viel spaß
wo war denn jetzt ist der knast gewesen
dass sie sind die ersten drei charaktere
die wir haben und wir haben noch in ihr
bett practice bisschen unhöflich kann
vielleicht mal an maske ab denn hey
gefragt ist auf jeden fall auch der der
ist der ist ganz stark der kann nämlich
hier ganz weit die leute wegschubsen er
müsste fred nicht übel power haben wir
immer der haut die kugel weg und dann
eigentlich liegen wieder nur zu zwei
meter oder so das sind jetzt auf jeden
fall die vier jungs die wie die am start
haben ist die neue klick das sind
nämlich hier jimi blue ochsenknecht dann
haben wir hier
flipper dann haben wir noch einfach ingo
flamingo der ersten halbzeit habe und
wir haben hier natürlich auch noch fremd
und diese vier machen jetzt zusammen die
stadt und sicher allerdings muss ich
wirklich sagen dass mit der flamingo am
besten gefällt weil ich mit dem wirklich
einfach herum fliegen kann dadurch dass
ich rumfliegen dann habe ich jetzt
vielleicht sogar die möglichkeit diesen
paraglider der auch in dieser stadt
wieder vorhanden ist mal zu holen
übrigens ist die stadt ja auch einfach
viel größer als letztes städte die wir
hatten da hinten ist sowas in china
tempel die nächsten 10
simuliert werden also jetzt alle in die
der stadt hier stattfinden und ich
versuche jetzt mal eine punktlandung auf
dem furzkissen die nächsten paar werden
nur in dieser stadt hier stattfinden
weil das ganze einfach viel zu heiß ist
dass es ultra chillig wir haben hier
kommen wir haben sogar das hollywood
zeichen da hinten und als gold rot
dargestellt es wird demnächst alles hier
stattfinden ich hoffe euch gefällt dass
falls ihr euch das schon runter geladen
habt was ich denke weil es seit
vorgestern ist rausgekommen ist und
jetzt wohl auch nicht das allseits
bekannteste beste spieler der welt hilft
hat sie aber trotzdem schon irgendwelche
tipps kennt was man hier machen kann ob
man hier irgendwie mit einem schlitten
runter rutschen kann oder ob man wenn
hier mal hinzukommen würde ob man damit
irgendwie zum nordpol fahren kann oder
so dieses spiel alter wenn ihr da
irgendwas willst dann schreibt mir das
gerne in die kommentare dann kann ich ja
mal schauen ob ich da irgendwie coole
sache machen kann nach kuba wir haben
sogar der polizeistation diesmal da sind
sogar sträflinge ich dachte gerade
wirklich seinen sträflinge aber dann
tanzt wieder dieser blöde typ hier um
den muss einfach man muss seine lektion
erteilt werden diesen typen hier wenn
ich ein anleger steht unten scotty
mortel den ich jetzt angeblich lecker
und was ich auch gerade gewählt was ich
machen kann ist ich kann er drücken und
ich bin what the [ __ ] ich habe jetzt
gott die angelegt und kann jetzt eher
drücken und bin auf
scott keys kopf was macht ihr heute so
also ich flieg mit scotty gerade über
die stadt macht spaß nehme meine lieben
freunde wenn euch das video gefallen hat
wird scotty
lasten daumen hoch dutchess